it is a joy to be able to share some of
the material in the book I'm riding with
an audience I've been writing this book
for two years it's been a lot of fun but
it is essentially a solitary experience
to write a book I think I met most of
you just call me Stu and I'm gonna get
us some combinations here in a second
but if you have any questions you raise
your hand or if you're comfortable you
can just call outs - I don't mind come
on in I don't mind being interrupted
probably I should introduce myself I'm
Stuart Rachel's I haven't played chess
in 20 years but I think the pieces still
move the same way and I played from the
ages of 9 to 23 or from 1979 to 1993 and
I'm writing a book I'll tell you about
that in due course but I promise you
some combinations so let's do that all
these will be from for my games now I
don't actually think that there's a
logical place to begin here I think
chess is sort of like the ocean you just
dive in somewhere you start swimming so
why don't we start here with this
position this is a game actually in my
book even though I'm talking about
combinations this is not in one of the
tactics chapters this is just a rook and
mire piece ending game there's a
probably more tactics and in games and
people people realize so I was playing
white in this game against a player I
don't know name aqui con amore he was
around 2400 this is in the 1988 US Open
now this was a last round game right
last round games are pretty important in
terms of how you how are you gonna feel
on the way home okay so what's happening
here so we have a position of even
material reduced material why it is more
active here but black looks to have
things covered you probably think it
might be a draw the the only way that
white can try to make his piece is more
active these rook and Bishop are pretty
good right now
why could bring his King in a c5 but
that's really not going to do anything
black can give this check with his rook
if white wants to be aggressive and play
King d6 than just another check with the
rook and the King comes back and another
check of the rough why it's not doing
anything here but one one principle of
attacking is that if all your pieces are
in good squares if they're all
contributing to your attack see if you
can throw a pawn into the mix and so
this is the right first move b5 and
black is actually losing by force now
one reason I'm showing this game is
because my opponent obliged us by
playing what I would think is the main
line from this position played the most
natural moves signs says people see
danger coming and they do something
unaesthetic to avoid it but here here
we'll see what happens so b5 you place
pawn takes pawn I think that's what most
of us would want to play well I would
play and now I play a 6 ok now white is
threatening to get quite a strong pass
pawn here on b7 and then blacks pawn on
b5 will be weak and black will have
other problems so it as usual in chess
there's more than one way to lose but
black played I think and move most of us
would play Bishop c8 just trying to hold
hold that pawn and now we go a takes b7
Bishop takes
and now I was not interested in winning
Li pulling back on b5 but rather playing
g6 so black wants to stop this pawn
while I can F takes G six and now the
the point of all this has revealed east
six so White's
giving up all of his pawns but one but
the one remaining will be enough what
this move does in effect is it wins this
Bishop on b7 because blacks defense of
this Bishop blacks double defense is now
ilusory well I cannot capture a
recapture twice in the square because
this pawn will clean and black has no
defense here I'll show you what kind of
more he did which is as good as any at
least he set a trap for me here play
King's c8 now the trap is I have to take
this with the right piece with a bishop
I take of the rook then I lose my last
pawn boom rook takes c6 whoops that's a
shame so now of course if Bishop takes a
rock white's rook here hangs so I think
white in this position would do
something like rook takes g7 now this is
this could still be quite a long game I
think the fact that black has these two
pawns probably doesn't matter
I imagine white can win them pretty
easily without swapping rooks and then
we have the in game of rook and Bishop
versus rook and that the computers have
completely mapped out this endgame not
that any human being understands their
analysis but we can say for sure that
this position is drawn but in practice
white would have winning chances I mean
if you were playing in a blitz game
against Magnus Carlsen and you had
through the rook and he had the rook and
Bishop you should probably just resign
but it should be drawn okay
so King c8 now I played Bishop takes
Bishop check and so here's the thing he
just he cannot play rook takes Bishop or
he might as well he could just resign
really rook takes rook King takes rook
and now East seven and white makes a
queen has no problem picking out these
black pawns
so Bishop takes Bishop check and so
black plays King c7 and now the active
position of whites King is useful for
white because now the White King can
come in to the defense and black is
hosed well I'll show you the rest of the
game just cuz it's very quick it's very
quick kind of more he played b4 right
hope springs eternal maybe I'll take it
and lose something but I just play back
here that's nice he goes King date it
doesn't matter
check only legal move check only
sensible move King b6 and now black
reside because the white pawn will come
through to the queen square controlled
by White's Bishop position number one
all right let's move over here all right
again I had white in this game I was 13
years old at the time of this game
I think Doug might remember me from from
from those days now with the black
pieces was a fellow named Jay whitehead
this was in the world open in 1983 and
and Jay was a twenty five hundred two
years earlier Jay had won the u.s.
Junior closed and not a bad player I
played seven times in the rest Junior
closed and I felt very lucky to win it
once the other six were very very hard
indeed okay so Jay had really been out
playing me on the black side of ac3
Sicilian but his last move was careless
and so now I got my big chance here okay
white to move the first move that I
played here is d5 uncovering an attack
on blacks knight on b6 come on in if you
want y'all okay Bishop takes Knight is
threatened obviously what black wants to
do yeah also this pawn is threatened
okay bad stuff here black certainly
wants to play Knight takes pawn which
white head did play and now I got to
play this fun move Bishop h6 now got a
double attack threating Queen takes pawn
on e6 check as well as Queen takes pawn
j'adoube on g7 check now you might
wonder why would I play d5 I could have
played Bishop h6 immediately to create
this double attack why D 5
yeah that there's what's a tournament
going on with two world champions
Botvinnik and tall playing and Bob and
Nick was sort of this this old Stern
schoolmaster type and tall as a
swashbuckling tactician and Bob Nick the
sternal guy says to talk about the is
game that's going on Bob mixes says why
did you sacrifice that pawn and toss
that it was just in my way sometimes you
do sacrifice a pawn because it's in your
way you make a line clearing sacrifice
you want to open a rank or a file or a
diagonal this is not one of those
situations the reason that I wanted to
throw in the moves d5 Knight takes d5
it's because when blacks pay is on d5
unlike on b6 the rook on d6 evan is
unprotected
now this knight on d5 this is a very
nice to be a very nice square under
other under other circumstances but with
the specific tactics of this position
the night is really unhelpful on d5 it
covers f6 it covers a 7 those squares
will not be important and what's to
follow but the protection of the rook
will and here's the variation that
really shows blacks problem with that
undefended rook obviously you have to
look at the move pawn takes Bishop and
now we've got Queen takes pawn check so
blacks in check and this rook is hanging
on this square so black will try to
counter-attack against the whites rook
on h5 now I don't know what this
position would come out with if without
use moves d5 Knight takes d5 but in this
position white just cleans up because
why it doesn't have to lose this rook
first he comes back with check now black
can do whatever he wants here and now
this rook is taken with check and then y
can take the knight next move and be a
whole rook up so this is really the
variation that made me want to play my
pawn to d5
I'll show you what blacks best move is
here
what blacks best move is to meet this
double threat I didn't see this move
Whitehead did not see this move a
computer saw this move it's a retreat
retreats are difficult to see much
easier to see aggressive moves in chess
and the retreat is King g8 so the King
moves back opening up the defense along
the seventh rank for the rook on d7 and
okay White will go ahead with a smooth
check and black will hunker in with his
rook when f7 the rook on c8 is protected
by the Queen on c2 and the game will
continue like this Queen takes d5 like
to take this bishop and then white will
take this pawn because it's a free pawn
if it's free it's for me now we've
reached a position of equal material but
blacks King is very exposed here and
black has no quick way or slow way of
swapping any pieces so this is probably
on the border or something that's
winning for why they're not winning for
white but in practice black is in big
trouble
it's very hard to defend with your king
is gonna be wide open for the
foreseeable future with all these pieces
on the boards nevertheless that's what
jage have tried surely would have if
he'd seen it not only is this a
difficult move to see King g8 because
it's a retreat it's also difficult just
because black is very likely to be Sur
shell-shocked in this position things
have been going very well and suddenly I
got these aggressive moves flying at him
and so he tried to move g5 White has to
force two wins here let me show you
first the move I did not play I did not
well here's here's the line win number
one Queen takes a six check so White's
again just trying to with us rook on d7
and again black should counter-attack
and whites Rock okay next move rook
takes g5 check
exploiting the pen along the
sixth-ranked here black spawn being
penned by whites Queen a black place
King takes bishop and now this quiet
move rookie g3 what's the threat here
folks the threat checkmate in one move
Queen h3 and blacks got nothing black
just black and do almost nothing here
okay Knight f4 we can just look at this
for a moment here preventing the Queen
check now Queen takes f6 and it's going
to be made very soon here if black plays
Knight to g6 rook h3 is checkmate I've
heard that's good - checkmate your
opponent and if the black King or cheats
- 8 7 now the white queen comes to h4
we've got the same mating pattern with
the heavy pieces along the GNH file
blacks king is trapped okay so that that
would have been good
so I'm writing this book I do want to
say one thing about this variation I
just showed which is not a very hard
variation I did come up with it myself
it's it's it's a matter of old school
pride that the way I've been writing my
book 500 page book I've been doing all
the analysis myself and then having done
the analysis I've got a couple of
friends my my main computer interpreter
Dave Gertler in Delaware also my friend
Mark Califano sand Ohio has been very
useful to me so I do this analysis I
sent it to them they they open up
Houdini or stockfish I'd never touch
these programs myself and then they show
how all my analysis is completely wrong
and they send us back to me and then I
have to rewrite the book on this point
and as I've tried to tell Doug it's a
it's a longer process but it really
makes you appreciate the beauty of the
computer analysis to see what it does to
your own analysis when you think you've
done a good job it's it's it's the great
humbler it's just like the rating system
okay but what I did find here although I
didn't think about this check mating
pattern we just saw I played rook takes
g5 once I saw that move I really didn't
look for anything else and you should
probably know this mating pattern here
if pawn takes rook Queen takes pawn and
this is checkmate folks checkmate in is
the game and in fact problem ists are
composers would call this position a
pure mate because the squares around
blacks king are each covered by one and
only one white piece so it's a very
economical mating position not the
tournament players care if it's mate who
cares but every square be covered by 17
pieces
okay so whitehead saw through this what
did he do okay he's got a product he's
got this attacked this is a threat
he played rookie seven now I've been
thinking here's white for three or four
minutes and Whitehead surprised me by
resigning in this position so he was
waiting for just me to play the move
Queen to h5 check and the black king is
trapped here this is this is mate Queen
g6 is the only move Queen takes Queen
this is checkmate and I just did not see
this something about the geometry of
this position just rook g7 looked like
just cried out to me as the next move to
be played I was looking at rook takes
rook g7 now you're you're probably not
here just to be entertained you probably
want some advice that could be helpful
to you help you raise your rating and
prove your game and here's one piece of
advice I have if your opponent has a
winning move do not resign until he
makes it okay this is this has always
been good for me however however it was
okay really the J resigned even if I
continued to have a blind spot about
this Queen h5 check move even if I play
them if I was looking at it's it's more
than enough here King King e8 okay this
is very simple rook check Knight takes
now Queen takes east six so now why is
threatening maiden one on the night on
e7 black will defend it
Brooke c7 now Queen takes f6 this is
just obliterating two black white has an
extra pawn he has a huge attack he has a
stronger minor piece and even if black
were somehow to survive the onslaught of
the next five moves which is perhaps
unlikely white could probably just put
his Bishop on g5 and just throw his age
pawn down the board and black would be
helpless so okay I probably could have
taking care of this and myself although
it was nice to nice to have the opponent
resign you know he was so nice to me
after the game because I thought I'd
played such a great game and he said
well let's go take a look at it and then
he like showed me that my position stunk
to the whole game and he just made this
one bad move and of course the only
thing that would go in my book is the
position after the bad move yeah write
your own damn game we played dog you can
put that in your book okay
oh let's see no but it's but it's not
published yet I could still I could
still consider it okay let me see the
next one I got here okay overloaded I'll
pick it peace any peace
don't tell me I'm wrong Doug until I got
it all set up he's right
should do oh no it's just eat you any
more pieces I'm black abyss next woman
don't let me talk while I'm doing this I
cannot do two things at once it's
absolutely impossible rook e8 where's my
bishop free 7 g7 my a d4 pawn pawn why
to the point c4 rook on a one
how's it stuck okay okay you don't you
don't have to all right so I have the
black pieces here this is a game I
played and and the most prestigious
tournament I've ever played in the inter
zonal in 1990 if if you know how the Oh
at least how the old world championship
cycle worked once you get to the
Interzone --all i was one of seventy
people who might have played Kasparov
for the World Championship in this
three-year cycle no way I'm going to
make the cut to 16 I was very lucky to
make it to 70 so this is a 13 round
tournament in Manila that I played in
and I was one of the weakest players
there I got completely forgettable
results six points out of thirteen minus
one six and seven one more loss than win
and for this - score this forgettable
score
I finished ahead of Smith Slav chomsky
and poor - that's what the inner zonal
is like if you can avoid last place
you'll have something to brag about this
game this was a Queens gambit accepted
if you play that opening you might even
be able to recognize it's Queens gambit
accepted
we have even material here and and black
is equalized pretty easily in this
white should probably do something uh
kind of modest here but instead my
opponent who was 2400 feet a player from
China named lint ah he got aggressive
here and what whites whites position is
just not good enough to warrant
aggression now we can understand why I
wanted to play this move the night
cannot be taken on this square
why does angling for a fork here if
blacks rooks maybe white wants to play
as Queen to GeForce threatened checkmate
on g7 this sort of thing but I don't
know you always just have to you always
have to look at the specific tactics but
you've got one piece that's crossing the
Rubicon here and not a lot of other
white pieces to support it so actually
black will win here win by force at
least when a pawn it's probably enough
to win the game
I simply played Bishop f8 a slightly
defensive move but I'm attacking the
knight on e6 and then there's the white
pawn on e4 behind it that's in trouble
so if white plays 97 this is not going
to work anymore this Fork of the black
rooks because I'll rescue this rook
captures pawn in the process attacked
White's Queen the White Queen moves and
black other rook is free to move is
black is one a pawn on e4 the same thing
is true if the White Knight captures
this bishop I like to capture bishops of
my Knights but black doesn't recapture
the knight here black wins a pawn but I
can first play this what is this in
between move ition zoogs something like
that rook takes e4 taking a pawn
attacking the White Queen and when the
White Queen moves or white plays Bishop
e3 black recapture the knight with a
rook black swuan a pawn ok linty saw
this and this was not he wasn't
interested in playing Knight takes
bishop or Knight c7 he was interested in
trying to increase his attack with Queen
g4 he's really getting deeper and deeper
in trouble here but again this was his
idea he's defending his knight he's
renewing this threat of 97 with a fork
but now black plays I played queen c8
attacking the knight and now pinning the
night
now the knight can't move there's
nowhere a night on e six cannot move in
a way that protects a piece on g4 it
takes four moves for Knight to trick to
transfer from east six to g4 it follows
from the rules of chess it's probably
not worth complaining about so the
knight pinned cannot move
but again linty he foresaw this and he
had this idea that he would play this
smooth blow for blow rook d6 now the
cute idea here is well first of all
black cannot play Bishop takes rook
because checkmated one checkmate in the
game someone told me that was in the
u.s. you have a rule book at some point
yeah yeah Alex sure would make illegal
moves against me in speed chess and say
checkmate in the game and try to claim
the game that's I said yeah check means
again you just lost okay so the rook is
immune on d6 it protects the knight on
e6 and also opens up a threat against
Blacks Knight b6 so this is all looks
good here's the problem for white the
problem is that for all these tactics to
work for white the White Queen must be
on exactly the square g4 let me explain
first the white queen must be on the G
file if we move the Queen off the G file
then black disk plays Bishop takes rook
right there's no Queen g7 mate unless
the Queen is on the chief on second the
Queen must be on the h3 see a diagonal
must be if the Queen's on the G file but
not on this diagonal here then black
just plays rook takes Knight free night
okay so the Queen must be on the G file
it must be on this diagonal that leaves
one square that the Queen must be on and
so it is and therefore black's winning
move
h5 the white queen is overloaded
there's nothing Y can do with this Queen
now it doesn't lose big material if
Queen g6 still on the G file but not on
the diagonal black wins the pieces rook
takes nine or if the Queen takes this
pawn which in fact mr. linty did so
queen g6 was rook takes Knight Queen f5
move well now we're not on the G file
anymore allows the Bishop takes rook so
this move essentially ended the game and
again I'll just show you the last few
moves just because there's so few of
them white at least took a pawn here but
full piece Downey's should give it up
pretty soon but he tried a little
something here can't blame him rook
takes Knight losing more material rook
takes rook now you threw in a check here
I don't know he's just hoping I'll
blunder and play my Queen here and help
swipe my rook but of course I just play
this move and that's all she wrote
there should be three who knows queen c6
and whites her rook down so so white
resigning this one okay
all right next
need more pieces
and how I'd you and Doug does that look
good all right so this is uh this is as
much a story as anything else no no no
this is wrong this one's wrong what do
you one thank you all right start over
folks put roll the tape back okay so
let's see how old was I with this one
okay I was 16 all right I played 1011
tournament chess games this is the only
moment of any game that I played where I
played a a winning move and it was
totally by accident I had no idea that
it was a good move let me walk walk
through you what my thought process was
how this happened okay so I'm playing
white we have equal material here this
is in the US Open Black was a master
just John why gretchy John why gretchy
he's a couple hundred points lower than
me I think so I was hoping to win I had
not outplayed him at all in the game had
been quite an even game and we were both
in time trouble now I as White had two
minutes left to make five moves and
white recce had five minutes left to
make five moves and this is the days
before increments two minutes that's all
I had for the five moves and my flag was
rising those old analog mechanical
clocks or as I call them chess clocks
okay now another fact here is that me
and my opponent we had just made several
moves quickly that had changed the
nature of the position so when this
position arose I literally had not had a
second to think about it until my clock
was ticking with two minutes left in
five moves to make so I've got to think
fast here now the first move you want to
play first nobody looked at as Queen
takes pawn but okay I saw right away
this is a very standard tactic I can do
that
is black deflects the rook protecting
the Queen rook e1 check these two
squares are illegal
for the king to go to night covers that
Queen covers it so white must play route
takes rook or resign by Cologne except
to draw offer and now blacks just going
to swap rooks rook takes rook check rook
takes rook and whites queen is hanging
on d4 and black has won a queen for a
rook easy win for the black bits okay
that when I soft pretty fast the next
thing I looked at was even easier to
refute but the next thing that ran
through my head was just to play rook d2
just to try to get that rook out of my
hair but now now rook e1 again check and
for white to continue to play the game
in a second here he's gonna have to move
his Queen to f1 and get taken by black's
rook losing alright okay so this
probably accounts for the first five
seconds of my thinking on this position
and the next thing I thought about doing
very modest my pawns attacked here I
thought about playing like horn to a3
not only did I think about it my hand
actually reached out and I started to
make the move and as I started to make
the move I suddenly saw two very
frightening things fly could do to me in
this position
the first is to play rook takes pawn
well what's this King takes rook Queen
check on h2 King f1
okay it's not mate right away because
White's bishop on b7 covers this square
but I mean you're in time trouble right
who the hell knows what's Oh can I say
hell on the internet start the tape back
okay this scared me I had no idea about
that I didn't like the looks of that and
the other one might have even been
scarier a3 I feel his black is bleh look
on eight - III Oh God right if pawn
takes rook now the black Queen comes
down and delivers checkmate check here
checkmate here
I was not I nothing I had not been any
danger this game even though it had no
advantage and this totally freaked me
out suddenly it seemed like I was facing
a big attack my clock is ticking my flag
is hanging like I think the best way to
explain what happened next is that my
hand reached out and played queen g3 and
I hit the clock and to my great surprise
I realized after I hit my clock that
this move wins a piece why is it when a
piece so White's threatening blacks
Queen Queen takes Queen White's
threatening blacks Knight Queen takes
Knight black has no way to defend them
both all black can do which blight did
is to play Queen takes Queen check I
recaptured with this pawn now the
Knights trapped a very unusual turn of
events so so poor mr. white rocky was
not expecting this and he had five
minutes and he used up all his time
trying to find a way out of this and he
did and he played this this is as good
as he had in the position I played pawn
takes Knight
he played rook takes pawn we still have
two moves to the time control and it was
I can't tell you what an emotional
relief it was when his flag fell as he
played rook takes h3 now white is
probably winning in this position black
City get a couple pawns for the piece
this pawn will probably win the game for
white but the fact is I was so nervous
at this point I did not know whether I
was capable of making two more rational
moves and make it at the time control
was very happy in this game was over all
right
Lady Luck smiled on me in New Jersey oh
okay okay
what time do we start we start a little
late didn't we all right this will just
be a couple more hours okay I can
probably talk while I'm creating the
opening position this Queen go on her
own color is that right okay so this
next this next game was between me and
now my computer interpreter mr. Dave
Gertler this was the pivotal game in the
1982 US Junior Open I was 12 years old
Big Dave was 20 and this was an eighth
round event and Dave was six - no he won
his first six games blew away the
competition including the highest rated
player in the event I had five points
out of six trailing him by one one point
I had white and I'll just show this to
you from the beginning because the
crucial combinational part of the game
is pretty is pretty early okay I'm gonna
go faster these moves again I'm White
Knight f3 knight c6 so I played the
pawns eonni I play a lot of garbage when
I was 12
although Magnus Carlsen played this a
couple of times by a 6 d4 Knight takes
e4 d5 very well-known theory Dave knew
is gonna play the pawns yani place
Knight b8 I think this is a good line I
think it's a smart line for Black Knight
takes pawn Bishop c5 that's a good
square Queen comes out here makes a
double attack well I can take an F to
you but it's it's kind of risky I
thought black couldn't take enough - but
the computer says he can so alright fair
enough
Queen takes e4 okay so blacks sacrificed
a piece but it's a very temporary
White's got this pin situation on the
e-file he could lose his Queen to rook
e8 now I I just I moved too quickly I
forgot what the line was I moved too
quickly I played this move it's a bad
move Dave plays a queen e7 he wins back
his piece takes it I Castle he develops
rook e8 I played Bishop f3 and I
actually I offer to draw here I didn't
like what I'd done with my position I
needed to win for the tournament but
after 12 moves is why to offer draw
because I've played so badly black is
sort of playing the white pieces at this
point like it's better development nice
Bishop control the e-file going pretty
well for black Dave makes a courageous
decision despite being 6 no in the event
he declines with a bang
plays b5 attacks like Queen and I did
not play Queen takes b5 because I've got
this problem of a skewer the bishop
attacking my queen and getting my rook
down here okay I saw that much
so I move my queen back to b3 now here's
the $64,000 question of this game
black queen 1 is that a good move or bad
news I'm not really asking you you know
I'll answer this question of 3 seconds
but I think for my opponents point of
view he was 6 no in the event he had an
obvious advantage as black after 12
moves it can kind of make you feel a bit
invincible so he thought is his manifest
destiny here and he's gonna easily crush
me with this move it's actually the
losing move this looks like it's a black
to play in wind position it's actually
white white to play and win okay Queen
e1
so now rook takes Queen well this is
matin one alright I saw that one and
black is now himself threatening made
into this Bishop takes F to check on the
f2 pawn the King comes over to the
corner queen takes rook that's mate
actually black is a second made into
threat he aside from Bishop takes pawn
check black is also threatening Queen
takes pawn check it's a little more
obnoxious way to do it
rook takes Queen black plays rook e1 now
that's that ends the game they say
checkmate
okay so clearly f2 has got to be
defended by white and them how can white
do it maybe Dave thought i play my queen
of c2 to defend okay not that White's
not going to lose right away here but
black is now I got this attractive move
attacking the white queen right again
the white queen cannot take the bishop
because we're back to the main two
situation an f2 so white has to do
something ugly clogging in is already
undeveloped Queen side Queen d2 black
Lehrer Treatise Queen
very nice for black game is not over but
very nice position for black if I if I
if I want to lose pretty quickly here I
should play g3 and allow Bishop h3 this
is this isn't this is no fun for white
there's gonna be a quiz and all this
later all right now what I did play is a
move that Dave saw I played Bishop III
cutting off that Bishop on the f2 Square
and blacks queen is actually trapped
here but Dave thought that I was losing
a piece to rook takes Bishop which he
played and now the idea this rook takes
Bishop still if rook takes Queen where
it takes rook is mate that's unchanged
pawn takes rook allows Bishop takes pawn
check now only legal move king tux in
the corner and Queen takes rook his mate
this is what Dave saw do mr. Gertler my
wonderful computer assistant latest said
that his problem was where's my bee
hopper I took him away real takes bishop
Dave later said that his problem was he
was focusing on the center and on the
King side and he just did not think
about this in between move here that I
flied night a3 a rude awakening for
black so now black has taken a piece but
now White's connected his rooks the
threat of the Queen is real and blacks
only moved to save his Queen which he
played his Queen d2 and now I was simply
able to chop off his rook with my pawn
now again I was I was 12 I don't blame
anything on being 12 I got a good game
to show you a lady was 11 but
I actually didn't see that I also had
this move here trapping blacks queen
it's probably about equivalent that
wouldn't move I played both moves when
material pawn takes rook and now to
repeat something I've said before I'll
uh I'll show you the rest of the game
just cuz it's so brief at this point
white goes down very quickly here he
checks so he's got one point for the
exchange but he won't have it for long
not only is white won the exchange here
for a pawn but White's completed his
development in the process and he
White's Knight is on a three right a
knight on the rim is grim
a knight on the side I shall not abide
but this Knight is now about to assume a
very strong position on b5 because black
just does not have time for this because
of his back ranked weakness rook a e1
black resigns because a Queens attack
and rook e8 mate is there at the Queen
moves so he cannot stop to protect this
pawn instead he asked to defend his back
rank what she did with Bishop d7 now I
win my pawn back now White's up a rook
for a minor piece black still has to get
developed threatening this pawn on c7
Dave goes Knight a six and now I played
this I think this is a good move Queen
c4 now I have the idea of maybe
uncovering attack on this night and like
really should complete his development
here if he's gonna keep playing and I
would keep playing maybe you should
probably play rook e8 here complete his
development now I was pretty greedy
twelve-year-old I probably would have
taken that pawn there which wins our
pawn whites Knight can be taken but why
is uncovered attack on blacks night
night for Knight isn't even trade but
the point on a7 is in White's pocket I
don't know maybe maybe be even stronger
for white after rook e8 to play b4
bishop b6
a for White has the initiative here one
way or the other not good for the black
bits
Dave's did not want to lose any more
pawns
j'adoube so after my queen went to c4 he
just retreated his Queen 286 right away
now the white knight can't take any
pawns in this position without without
losing the knight Knight takes pawn
Queen takes Knight defending the knight
on d6 and that sort of thing but this
accelerated blacks demise because after
Queen 6 I played a very simple move
Knight d4 now I'm threatening Queen
takes Knight if black had played Bishop
takes Knight which she did not do
I would recapture with a pawn for sure
renewing the threat if Queen takes
Knight which is not an easy piece to
defend in this position so instead Dave
made the undeveloped amove Knight v8 my
hero mikkel tall used to say of these
moves the pieces are getting ready for
the next game and now now Dave packed it
in he resigned in this position that's
bad very bad being exchanged down when
you're the when you're the exchange down
and you've got undeveloped pieces then
that's trouble